[Music]
all right hi everyone welcome to our
talk today we're going to talk about
continuous integration and continuous
delivery solutions for hybrid and multi
cloud customers we're very excited to
have you here again on day two of next
and for sticking with us yesterday if
you happen to catch it we did a talk on
CI CCD for service that was focused on
sort of cloud native modern service
applications and infrastructure this one
is sort of kind of the opposite this one
is focused on large enterprises
companies who are living in sort of a
world where you have on-prem
applications as well as cloud and you
have different services running on
multiple clouds and kind of some of the
challenges that may present around
developer tooling in those ecosystems so
this is a stat that ears actually stared
shared yesterday from rightscale 80% of
enterprises are adopting a hybrid multi
cloud strategy and I think there's a lot
of talk over time around like different
words around cloud native and tier 1 and
tier 2 and lift and shift and all these
different terms and I think the world
that we've arrived at now is that this
is just kind of the new normal for a lot
of different reasons whether it's cost
or control or not really seeing the
benefit to moving quite yet and and also
sort of leveraging the best aspects of
the different cloud providers
increasingly enterprises are adopting
strategies where they are deploying
different services to different places
and there's a lot of challenges between
interacting between on-prem resources
and the cloud so what do we mean by
hybrid and multi cloud it's one of those
words kind of like serverless kind of
like DevOps that depending on who you
ask and what time of day it is you
probably get a different definition I
think the first thing that comes to mind
is running applications so we've had a
bunch of announcements so far around gke
on Prem server lists things like that
and that's often where your mind goes
first you think about applications so
running kubernetes on prem or an
kubernetes on communities engine or
running out other clouds and for that
if you've sort of looked at Google or
been in the space long you might be
familiar with spinnaker spinnaker is our
open source multi-cloud continuous
delivery platform that we co-developed
with Netflix so Netflix started this
it's what they use for all their
continuous delivery and there are some
other talks that are gonna be focused
really explicitly on this target is
giving a talk this afternoon that should
be really great about how they use
spinnaker to deploy to both their
on-prem retail stores and the cloud and
it's really set up for sort of complex
sequencing and rollout orchestration so
these are just kind of all the different
use cases though that often fall under
the hybrid umbrella as we talk to
customers and we say well what kind of
what what do you mean by hybrid we get
all sorts of different answers so things
around a multi cloud deployment edge
computing invoking legacy dependencies
but for today we're gonna focus on
largely the context of CI and continuous
integration so for CI workloads they
look a lot different than running
applications right they're sort of more
batch like you have to deal with things
like configuration management peak
workloads multiple platforms things like
that and what we find is that a lot of
companies who have on-prem build
dependencies so things like gitlab or
github enterprise or bitbucket
enterprise or on-prem artifactory at
build time you need you need to be able
to securely access these resources so
that you can actually build and test
your code the problem is that because
these things are on Prem you need to
securely access them you are now sort of
in the business of having to run your
own CI CI server farm if everything is
in the cloud then of course you can use
a cloud hosted solution and offload a
lot of that management and architecture
to someone else but the problem is that
if any one of these things source code
artifacts other things like databases
and license servers are on Prem then
your CI server needs to be on Prem as
well and as we talk to customers really
what they what they kind of want is
something like this they don't really
not want to necessarily have to move
their source code to the cloud they
don't want to have to sort of move
license servers to the cloud or maybe
they they just can't with the way their
company is set up but they would love to
be able to offload all of that
infrastructure and that they're
investing too many resources
in order to scale up to the number of
builds that they are that they're
running so we're going to talk a little
bit about that today
one of the announcements earlier today
and so one of the takeaways I think is
that you can use managed CI with on-prem
resources and we're going to give a demo
a little bit later and talk about some
new solutions for Google cloud about how
this is possible if you're at the
keynote this morning you saw one of the
announcements that we're really excited
about is around K native so if you are
in the category where you're running
workloads on Prem and on top of
kubernetes this is a new series of
open-source components that adds a new
layer of primitives on top of kubernetes
one of which is called K native build
and that lets you as more of a
first-class way define build builds that
can run on top of kubernetes but for our
talk we're gonna focus on how can I can
I offload this all together so Before we
jump into that I want to I want to do a
quick little story this is gonna be
interactive I'm gonna describe some of
the some of the conversations we have
with a customer about their current
situation and if anyone can sort of
guess who this is I want you to please
feel free to raise your hand shout it
out take a wild guess there are no wrong
answers so this is so this company had a
self-hosted CI system and they had a
couple developer teams who were building
software and they were running tests on
their local workstation and they were
building software and that was kind of
working fine but after a while they were
having trouble they're having
inconsistent build environments they're
getting weird irregularities between
their workstations and so they decided
hey let's set up a dedicated CI server
so they set up a CI server farm they
installed Jenkins or something like that
and sort of wrapped it with things like
events and workflow and out the other
side they would have things like logs
and build artifacts and this works
pretty well for a while and other
companies and teams inside the
organization said hey this this is
looking actually pretty good we want to
get in on this
so they started saying could we use the
same CI system and so they join and they
started sending even more builds and
what happened is that the more builds
they sent they started running into
problems things like bottlenecks things
like queuing and so they said hey you
know what why don't we should get like a
dedicated team that can handle this so
maybe it's somebody on the team maybe
it's a new dedicated team but someone
said hey you you're responsible now for
making
that this thing is working that our
developers can continue iterating on
code and this worked pretty well too but
the company kept growing and the team
kept growing and so they kept sending
more bills and this introduced new
issues they were building all sorts of
new different types of applications so
they kind of continued to grow the team
and around this time they said you know
this is kind of actually like a formal
job so we should sort of give this team
a name so we called it like the
platform's team or the tools team or the
ops team and they were really
responsible for building out this
infrastructure for their developers and
they said you know not only can we
actually manage our machines but we can
actually add a lot of value here so we
could do things like provide more logic
around releases and rollouts things like
Canaries we can do things like security
and analytics so that we can measure
things like mean time to release and
prove overtime and management said you
know that that sounds actually like a
like a pretty good idea so we grew that
team a little bit so that kept growing
but the company kept growing we kept
adding more developers we kept adding
more builds and at this point in time
they said gee it looks like we've
actually built like an entire CI CD
infrastructure we should give this thing
a name so we call it the thing like the
accelerator or they're like the pipeline
factory or something like that and they
sort of they sort of productize that
internally present it to developers and
sort of say you know you don't need
really to think about this this is kind
of our own little internal CI product so
the team grew even more but what
happened is this kind of never ended the
team kept growing the bills kept coming
and the builds they just the problems
they never really stopped right so what
we found is that in talking to customers
the number of builds and tested they're
running are actually growing super
linearly to the size of their team so if
their engineering team is kind of going
like this because of modern best
practices like CI their build volume is
actually kind of going like this and
what's happening is that you're
constantly racing against time you can
sort of see the trend line where it's
going and your infrastructure is just
keeping up with the amount of builds
that you can do and what we found is
that customers are actually doing kind
of crazy things they're actually doing
things like throttling the number of
bills that their developers run by not
adding new features so they're sort of
discouraging builds because the
infrastructure can't really handle it
all right so who was it anyone have any
guesses well let me ask you this wait
does this sound like any of you here
yeah it's everybody this is everybody
everybody's gone through this there's a
Googler he calls us the Rube Goldberg
machine builder problem so if you're
familiar with Rube Goldberg machines we
basically keep building machines that
build other machines and it starts
innocently enough right you're like oh I
need to run a couple builds oh I need a
couple run a couple triggers oh now I
want to get some metadata now I want to
do some more workflow and before you
know it you've reinvented the wheel
you've created a whole C icd
infrastructure and yes Google was
absolutely a right answer we're no
exception back in 2015 we were running
800,000 builds a day in 2018 that number
is already up to four million our
engineering team has not grown at this
same pace and honestly this number is
continues to go up today that's because
the builds never stop we don't see this
trend ending any time soon we have
things like now ml workloads and IOT and
server lists and the number of builds
and tests are just going to continue to
grow faster and faster so this is kind
of the first takeaway of our talk today
is that CI I think fundamentally is a
compute problem we tend to think of it
as kind of a workflow problem it's like
oh if I can if I can write just the
right number of scripts and automate
them in just the right way I can run CI
CD and that's absolutely true the
problem is that you then actually need
to run those workloads somewhere and CI
compute looks really different it's
batch workloads it's configuration
management it's crazy things like nested
virtualization and this has a real cost
to it so McKinsey did a recent study and
found that application developers spend
a third of their time as system
engineers so this is things like
debugging builds standing up servers I
know has anyone here ever kind of
upgraded the version of Jenkins that was
running it just completely wiped out
their entire system yeah yeah I have so
how can we sort of move past this so if
we look back at our diagram here a lot
of customers that we talk to say you
know there's a lot of value that we're
bringing to our company around kind of
the releases and rollouts and the
product itself but this whole Middle
area of machine management we really
love to move to the cloud we would like
to offload all of this and just stop
having to think about it and then that
lets us get back to things that really
are more important so things like
improving our meantime to release
reducing vulnerabilities keeping our
company out of the headlines with
downtime and things like that so the
good news is is that we're here to help
and we are introducing this week cloud
build so this was announced yesterday
it's a hosted CI ACD platform for
increasing developer velocity so that
you and your teams can develop more
quickly and more safely so as a brief
history we launched this a year ago as
container builder container builder was
a hosted solution to build docker images
and push them up to container registry
in a safe and reusable way and our
vision for this was always a little bit
grander we realized that not only can we
build containers using this approach but
we can do things like build tar balls
and binaries and run sort of different
tasks and you could point it out a git
repository set up a trigger so that when
you did it get push it would automate
that for you with the cloud build
announcement today we have a couple
features as well that we're announcing
the first is that you'll notice that
this is now top-level in the cloud
console so if you go to the cloud
console under tools you'll now see cloud
build we added support for first-class
artifacts so the same way you can build
and push images and associate that with
your builds you can out build other
artifacts like binaries and tar balls as
well and push those up to cloud storage
we also added support for file path
triggers and this lets you filter your
triggers based on certain files or
subdirectories that have changed and we
have two other features in private alpha
right now they're going to be coming
soon one is a much deeper integration
with github so we're adding native
support for pull requests posting status
back to the checks API that they just
recently announced as well as creating
triggers programmatically via the API
and the last is a brand new results UI
that we demoed yesterday that helps
developers debug builds faster and get
more of like a dashboard like view over
their projects so you know this all
sounds great Christopher but I kind of
thought the talk was about hybrid and
multi cloud this doesn't really help me
this is still a cloud hosted service I
still have fundamental security issues
about it interacting with on Prem
resources so today we're also excited to
announce something else cloud build
custom workers so cloud build custom
workers is a new feature of cloud build
it's in a
access right now it's gonna be available
soon and what it does is it lets you
securely connect cloud build workers to
your on-prem resources so let's take a
little bit of a look at how this
actually works so this is my GCP project
here and the way cloud build works today
is that from my GCP project i request a
build to cloud build cloud build then
actually runs that build on a worker vm
which is just a Google compute engine VM
in a shared pool that we manage and run
every build on a new VM so you send us a
build request we provision it we grab
one of the VMS from the worker pool run
your build and then spin it down and so
every build runs its own machine so it's
completely isolated and secure the
problem is that in an on-prem scenario
you're behind some firewall or private
network restrictions so when that worker
goes to access your source code or push
to a registry it can't it hits the
firewall
doesn't have permissions so that's not
going to work so we need to do something
else so with custom workers instead of
running builds on a shared worker pool
up in the cloud we're gonna run workers
inside of a GCP project that you own and
control and run builds there now because
this is running in your GCP project you
can use VPC or virtual private cloud to
connect that project to your private
network through peering or sharing and
now that worker can securely talk to and
access your on-prem resources and what's
really great is to is to realize about
this is that this is still a managed
service so these workers these GCE VMs
that are running inside your project you
have complete control over you can
access you can delete you can configure
but they're completely managed by cloud
build so you just tell us how big you
were pool size you want it to be what
kind of machine type you use and cloud
build will still be responsible for
delegating builds to it spinning up new
VMs maintaining that pool managing the
pool size making sure that it's up ready
and available so let's actually see this
in action so we're gonna jump over to a
demo for a second
thank you and so for this for this
instance we've set up two projects in
GCP so the first project is my on-prem
project and inside of this project I
have I have installed a get lab instance
so I'm running a self-hosted instance of
get lab where I have my source code in
my repository and then have a separate
GCP project for my custom worker pool
and inside of this custom worker pool
I'm going to use VPC appearing to setup
a secure connection so this is my
network that I've created it's called my
network and I connected it to my GCB
on-prem project and if I go over to my
GCB on-prem project and I look at the
VPC network there you'll see that I've
created its equivalent so that now these
two networks are securely talking to
each other and if I go back to my custom
worker project here and look under
compute engine
we'll see our worker pool so these are
GCE worker VMs that have been spun up
and managed by cloud build inside of
your project so we should be good to go
here so if I go over to our repository
here this is our git lab repo we have a
pretty simple application setup we have
a simple ruby app and let's just go in
and make an arbitrary change to our
docker file so I'm going to commit that
change and then if I go back to my
project and look at cloud build here we
should see that a new build has
successfully kicked off so if I jump in
here this is our build and we're gonna
run a few steps here so these are build
steps this is the cloud build convention
for running sort of jobs or tasks as
part of your build and if we step
through these we're gonna hope it's
already done it's pretty fast runs on
Google Network we're gonna fetch
credentials from cloud storage we're
gonna decrypt those credentials with the
built-in integration with kms which is
Google's key management service we're
then going to configure get do a git
clone to fetch our source code from the
and then build our image and push it to
the registry and that all works pretty
well and the way that we wired this up
is we use cloud functions to act as a
bridge between the source repo event and
the actual invocation of the bill so if
we go over to cloud functions as well in
our project we previously had set up
this function so this function listens
for webhook events rootkit lab and then
runs a build and so these are the same
build steps that we just saw we fetch
potentials we build the image and we
push it to the registry and if we go
back over to get lab and look at our
integrations we'll see that we had
previously set up a web hook pointing at
that cloud function so now every time we
make a change and we do a push or tag or
do a merge event it'll send that web
hook up to our cloud function the club
function will hear it kick off the build
and run it on cloud built so that was
great but we haven't actually shown this
running on our custom workers this would
roughly look the same if you were
running on the shared pool so let's
let's actually split this out and do
these side-by-side so this is our worker
pool here and if we jump back over to
our project here and go to our functions
let's let's kick off a few builds see
this happening so I'm gonna run a couple
tests one two let's say four builds and
go back to our workers and refresh here
we should see and sure enough our builds
are running on our custom worker pool
and if we keep refreshing
we should ultimately get to around four
new VMs and so what's happening is that
cloud build has sent the build to one of
our GCE workers and now it's in the
background spinning up a new VM to
replace it so that the next build that
comes in the VM is will pre-warmed and
ready to go and if we keep refreshing
this we'll see this sort of happen over
time and we're up to now yeah our four
VMs running and if we kept going with
this we'd eventually see that it would
go back down to five as those builds
would complete the VMs would just be
picked off
and if we go over our terminal here and
do an API response here and hit our get
endpoint for the worker pool we can see
the configuration that we had previously
used to set up our pool so again this is
custom workers you are in full control
and you own this so this is the project
that we hit invoke this n we set our
worker count to five we're running in
multiple regions for redundancy reasons
running on n one standard one machines
and we set up our own private network
now I really want to call out a couple
of the highlights here which I think are
particularly cool even outside of the
on-prem stuff so these this is all up to
you so we set our worker pool at five so
that you know for the sake of the demo
but this is really subject to your own
GCP quota you can set this to five you
can set it to 500 you can set it to
5,000 it doesn't really matter it's
gonna work and the other part is machine
type so if you're familiar with cloud
build the shared pool that we run builds
on are all and one standard one machines
and they're pre-warmed we do offer to
hire CPU machines a high CPU eight and a
high CPU 32 but they're not pre-warmed
so that you have to wait for spin up
time and usually the beefier machine
kind of makes up for it but we hear
frequently from users that they have
different requirements they want machine
with more RAM they want to pre-warmed
compute they may want I don't knows 64
cores who knows so you can now
completely configure that yourself so
any GCE VM machine type that's available
you can configure for your pool so you
have a pre-warmed fool of any machine
type of any size you want that's
dedicated just for you and your builds
so if you jump back over to our project
here we're gonna show kind of one more
interesting thing so one of things we
hear from customers a lot as well is
that you know this is great but I'm not
starting from scratch I already have a
CI system set up I'm using Jenkins I'm
using build kite I've built my own
homegrown system something like that and
I really I'm sick and tired of people
trying to convince me that I need to
rewrite the whole thing and migrate this
whole workload and I need to do it by q4
it's just not gonna happen I still have
a business to run so what's great is
that because cloud build is it's also
kind of a build as a service type
solution and has an API it works from
the cloud SDK and you can use it as well
from your existing CI setups to simply
offload the build infrastructure piece
so we're gonna switch to a different
project here where where we're using get
labs built in CI ACD functionality so
git lab is really great it comes with a
lot of features beyond just the source
repo run continuous integration
continuous delivery and actually I want
to give a shout out we worked closely
with gate lab on this so I want to say
thanks to Joshua Priyanka and Sid who
were really helpful in helping set this
all up but if we go in here and we go
look at our git lab CI file we can see
that we are building a docker image
using what I think is it's probably the
way the majority of users do this which
is running a CI Runner
probably a kubernetes instance running
locally and doing a docker and docker
build so for anyone doing docker built
this way you're probably aware of some
of the security limitations around this
so when you're doing a docker build you
need access to the docker daemon which
gives you route access which is sort of
a fundamental security risk in that
malicious code can potentially take over
your node break out of the box and
introduce a lot of issues now we get it
this is sort of the way that most people
do it because the idea of creating your
own tool of isolated VMs and spinning up
and speeding down VMs is a lot of work
but if you're doing darker and darker
you're aware of kind of some of the
latency and security issues so what we
can do with a few lines of code is
simply swap this out and offload all of
our builds to cloud build so we have a
merge request already queued up for this
so we're gonna jump over here and if we
look at the code changes that we made
see how those colors showed up pretty
good we'll see that we removed the steps
where we're doing docker log in docker
build and docker push and we've replaced
it with our cloud build a ml file which
is the cloud build build config and
we're gonna do the same steps we're
gonna do a docker login docker build and
dr. push to the registry we're then
going to submit the build using the G
cloud build submit command and what this
will do is that this will move the the
job or the docker build from our own CI
runner that we had to provision in
self-manage and over to cloud build so
if we go over to our pipelines and run
it and we're on our cloud build branch
here this will kick off what's really
great about this is that while this
build is running you'll notice that all
the rest of my pipeline hasn't had to
change so all the things that I'm gonna
do after my image gets built things like
that I'm doing a get lab like checking
code quality running container scans the
dependencies scans just works as is so
with very minimal change I've been able
to offload if ton of a ton of the work
and effort that I normally have to do in
order to get this set up so this is
gonna run through and if we wanted to
jump into as well we could see the logs
here you can see the steps that are
running we're building the image pushing
the image of the registry it's
successfully succeeded and if we refresh
should should be done and we've moved on
with the rest of our pipeline and we can
see our worker pool is back down to five
now and what's this what this lets us do
is go back over to our own project and
go ahead and actually delete a delete
our CI runner that we had previously set
up because we don't need it anymore
it's not our problem
so if we switch back to the presentation
let's just sort of recap what we did we
were able to spin down our own
kubernetes cluster for doing builds
offload that to the cloud and using VPC
it connect multiple GCP projects to a
private network and use a hosted build
infrastructure as a service so what are
some of the benefits of custom workers
first it's managed infrastructure cloud
build is managing and provisioning this
pool for you so you don't have to worry
about it
the second I think it's highly
configurable so we showed the API get
call you can pick your machine type here
you can pick your pool size even
configure on network settings and this
is just the beginning having dedicated
pools per customer lets us do a lot of
things that with shared pools aren't
really feasible and already from the EAP
we're getting a lot of feedback around
possibilities here so things like
caching images adding persistent disks
letting you cache dependencies on the
work or ahead of time as opposed to
fetching them during builds to speed up
builds also things like supporting
multiple regions restricted IP ranges
things like that so a lot of this is on
our roadmap but it's definitely on our
radar and something we're hearing about
from customers as as of a area of
interest and the last is we should talk
about pricing I guess I suppose so this
is metered billing and now again these
are compute engine VMs running inside
your GCP project so you pay for the
compute directly so whatever your
current agreement is with with Google
for how you pay for VMs its per minute
and it's just subject to the regular GCE
usage and there's no additional overhead
so you pay for the GCE VMs and storage
costs and you basically get cloud build
for free so if we go back to our diagram
here and we sort of look at what our
goal was that we were hoping to achieve
we really kind of wanted to do something
like this we wanted our build
dependencies to say on-prem and we want
to continue to Gration continues
integration to run in the cloud and I
think we were able to achieve that using
cloud built and what's really great is
that as we
showed you don't actually have to
rewrite your whole entire CI
infrastructure so if you're currently
running on Prem CI with something like
Jenkins or teamcity or you wrote your
own infrastructure solution you can
leverage cloud build is to replace kind
of your build agents or your runners in
order to offload that compute workload
and because the worker is running in an
on-prem network you can now talk to
resources like repos and artifacts so
one thing I do want to touch upon before
we go further is how sort of K native
and some of the other on-premise
solutions kind of work in this world so
we talked a little bit at the beginning
but this is for people who really want
to offload the workload if you really
you know like the idea of building out
your own infrastructure we definitely
recommend using kubernetes as sort of an
underlying component it deals with a lot
of the issues for you things like auto
scaling things like caching and if you
take a look at K native you'll find some
new primitives that make it even easier
for you to do that so if we look at some
of our takeaways two big ones CI is I
think it's at the end of the day a
compute problem I think anyone here who
has to manage it is on the hook for it
knows that you spent some nights and
weekends
having to debug builds having to deal
with infrastructure you can see the
trend line and node that sort of you're
going to run out of capacity by q2 next
year and that you know you need help so
that's what we're here for and cloud
build custom workers is a really great
solution for for enabling this and this
is because again the builds never stop
thank you very much that was the
president
[Music]